what is up with this look I'm obsessed
with you right now people are saying
Marilyn that wasn't the inspiration but
I will take it hot thank you so much I
feel relieved in Tosh
no it's call me and it's due balmy but I
feel so good in it I feel confident and
I feel like a strong woman it's like a
ladies night tonight though you know
what I mean girls are gonna throw down
and you know I'm all about female
empowerment so I'm very excited we have
JLo we have Mariah we have cardi we're
about to get this thing popping now
Taylor has been known to dance in the
front row of many award shows
can you take over from her tonight well
Hershey yeah I could I could I could
I'll try my best I'm mad as I'm out you
know I'm a good dancer but I like to get
a little down and dirty so we'll see and
again I might freak out how is the
reaction to you your solo you've always
collaborated top ten right now radio
it's amazing so and like on your own
yeah it's incredible it's been an
amazing journey and there's so much more
to come and a lot of stuff we're working
on and it's all the stuff that's about
to happen is really what's the new goal
because like we started and then there
were goals like I want to hit everyone
it grabbed me because we're dominating
I'm nominated for two awards tonight but
I love a name and I love a Grammy you
already have did you practice your
speech in the car I've been practicing
my speech in the mirror but I don't know
that's a long shot but I think that if
you put something in the universe it
happens yes now do you have a sexy sexy
date tonight no I don't have any date I
want to find a nice guy oh I don't know
I know everyone wear Entertainment
Tonight who do you want like et
Matchmaker somebody who is not doesn't
have a stick up there yeah and they
there this daisen thing they're the
greatest thing ever happened to mankind
somebody's just funny and like they
don't exist
they're a Hollywood guy are you into
Hollywood guys I think some of them are
really high getting Michael B Jordan is
so hot but I think he's in a
relationship I don't know but like none
of them really cannot for me
maybe I'm very intimidating that's what
I heard or I'm just crazy
[Music]